bachelor on processes or data one me me
batch at the time but at times you might
need to process the examples one at a
time let's see how you can adapt your
network to do that recall that during
training here are the equations you just
implement national within a single
mini-batches sum over that mini batch of
the zi values to compute the mean so
here you're just summing over the
examples in one mini batch I'm using M
to denote the number of examples in the
mini batch not not in the whole training
set then you compute the variance and
then you compute the norm by scaling by
the mean and standard deviation what
that's on added for numerical stability
and then V tilde is taking Z norm and
rescaling by gamma and beta so notice
that mu and Sigma squared which you need
for this scaling calculation are
computed on the entire mini value but at
times you might not have a mini batch of
64 128 alternative Pacific examples to
process at the same time so you need
some different way of coming up with mu
and Sigma squared and if just one
example taking the mean and variance of
that one example doesn't make sense so
what's actually done in order to apply
your neural network at test time is to
come up with some separate estimate of
mu and Sigma squared and in typical
implementations of national what you do
is estimate this using a exponentially
weighted average where the average is
across the mini batches so to be very
concrete here's what I mean
let's pick some layer L and let's say
you're going through mini batches x1 x2
together with the corresponding values
of Y and so on
so when training on x1 for that layer L
you get some new L and in fact I'm going
to write this as new for the first mini
batch and that lane
and then when you train on the second
mini batch for that layer and that mean
about you and there was some second
value of you and then for the third mini
batch in this hidden layer you end up
with some third value for MU so just as
means for how to use the exponentially
weighted average to compute the mean of
theta1 theta2 theta3 when you are trying
to compute a exponentially weighted
average of the current temperature you
will do that to keep track of so what's
the latest average value of this mean
vector your seat so that exponentially
weighted average becomes your estimate
for what the mean of the B's is for that
hidden layer and similarly you'd use an
exponentially weighted average to keep
track of these values of Sigma squared
that you see on the first mini batch in
that layer Sigma squared then you see on
a second mini batch and so on so you
keep a running average of the MU and the
Sigma square that you're seeing for each
layer as you train the neural network
across different mini batches then
finally at test time what you do is in
place of this equation you would just
compute Z norm using whatever value you
see you have and using your
exponentially weighted average of the MU
and Sigma squared whatever was the
latest value you have to do the scaling
here and then you would compute each
other on your one test example using
that Z norm that we just computed on the
left and using the beta and gamma
parameters then you'll you have learned
during your neural network training
process so the takeaway from this is
that during training time mu and Sigma
squared are computed on an entire mini
batch of you know say 64 and June 28 or
some number of examples but at test time
you might need to process a single
example at a time so the way to do that
is to estimate mu and Sigma squared from
your training
and there many ways to do that you
couldn't clearly run your whole training
set through your final network to get mu
and Sigma squared but in practice what
people usually do is implement an
exponentially weighted average where you
just keep track of the new and Sigma
squared values you've seen during
training and use an exponentially
weighted average also sometimes called a
running average to just get a rough
estimate of mu and Sigma squared and
then you use those values of MU and
Sigma square that test time to do the
scaling you need of the hidden unit
values z in practice this process is
pretty robust to the exact way you use
to estimate mu and Sigma squared so I
wouldn't worry too much about exactly
how you do this and if you're using a
deep learning framework they'll usually
have some default way to estimate mu and
Sigma squared tension work reasonably
well as well but in practice any
reasonable way to estimate the mean and
variance of your hidden unit values of Z
should work fine and test so that's it -
dome and using it I think you'll be able
to train much deeper networks and get
your learning album to run much more
quickly before we wrap up for this video
I want to share you some thoughts on
deep learning frameworks as well let's
start to talk about that in the next
video